we're endgame lecture brought to you
today by the letter e and who is the
highest rated player in the world whose
last name starts with EE I'll give you a
hint it's from Eric's home countries
never been to you've been there you've
been to your home country yeah I didn't
think so
anyone the Ukraine is weak now the
marshal paavo Aliannah
the third most famous ukrainian player
after Yvan Chuck and former world
champion ponomaryov I should have said
world champion and this is something you
didn't know because you guys don't know
anything
ponomaryov on the World Championship
again Steve on track they were the final
two yeah I said Ponomarev would win and
the response was who's that so wait why
is this here that's good all right
that's good all right that's the
funniest thing aren't you never heard
okay okay so a Leonov is one of the
world's most boring players so it was
easy to find n games he won because he
didn't win in the first 20 moves he's
normally bored three for the Ukraine and
now the Ukraine is getting pretty old so
very suspicious next Olympiad okay
he's playing the Indian player Gupta
this was a couple years ago at Aeroflot
okay black played Knight takes e5 check
or white did now there's a player you've
never heard of named Jakob gupta yukta
Minh and he was old he was born old
very strange guy and he was always the
same age I think he was like 78 when he
was born and about 100 years later he
was 78 and he lived in New York and he
was from the old country what country I
don't know because it was too old but he
had a funny thing that he would do he
lived in New York
and he was about 24 50 plus tax and he
would play nine and three against night
and two on the same side although it
would be drawn and that he would play
for money and give you drives five
minutes each and he would move around
doing nothing for five minutes until
your flag fell or your blunder now this
is slightly different because this point
on e5 is an on h7 in which case the
position would be a draw with correct
play now the position is more likely
winning because black can get past pawns
in the center because he has a passed
pawn already and f5 is going to create
another one so even though this looks
like a draw because it's three against
two it's very good winning chances okay
so the first thing any strong
grandmaster does in chess is what what's
the first thing you do oh wait you're
not strong grandmaster so you don't know
that's too bad not at the ridiculous
yeah come on would nigel ever do that
would kramnik and top alive ever do that
yeah no absolutely not okay the correct
answer which is very obvious is to
repeat okay so black repeated okay you
got it like that
okay good okay now you know he's a good
player okay and then he play King to g6
okay and white fork the King and pawn is
my comer would call it and then he
defended that way actually I have a
funny story to tell because I get paid
by the hour so I was playing in Michigan
a couple years ago and I drew in round 1
against the 1900 actually I beat Landrum
in that tournament so the mysteries of
life anyway I was a piece down the whole
game because I hung a piece and the
endgame we repeated just like this then
I claimed to draw and my opponent was
really like 1970s like what are you
talking about and I'm like the same
position occurred three times and he's
like what does that mean like what so
what so the arbiter came the arbiter was
rated like 1300 and he's like yeah and
the other guy is like I don't understand
what's going on like why are we still
playing and I said well the game we
repeated three times it's a draw
he said doesn't have to be three in a
row which I don't even know what that
means because you can't you can't repeat
the same position three times in a row
by impossible so I think what he meant
was the exact same was were made which
is obviously is in relevant so this
position if black played King e6 then
white could claim a draw by saying he
was going to play Knight c5 but not
actually playing it they actually played
ninety five minutes your opponent's turn
but if you say you're going to play 95
then you could claim a draw so if that
had happened then I wouldn't be showing
you this game that would be like
Eliana's worst end games
okay be played King e7 okay so black
wanted supply out five and and and so he
did okay and then normally when you have
fewer pawns and when I say normally it's
the case here you want to trade all the
pawns and the goal is to get one pawn
for a zero then you're not going to win
okay the knight moves away King protects
the pawn white plays h4 yeah that pawns
not not queening okay and unfortunately
for white when he plays h5 check instead
of getting counter play he's just going
to lose his pawn so he's sort of pushing
it to its doom King g5 King f2x clam
okay 97 notice how the knight protects
the F pawn and attacks the H pawn and
white just resigned
although if it was night and two against
tonight I wouldn't resign I would hope
for some kind of mistake but yeah you're
just going to lose your H pawn so back
here you know white probably had better
chances by not moving his H pawn and
just keeping it there and hoping the
black would blunder something like e for
check and you sack tonight for both puns
but Eliana wasn't going to do that he
was slowly but surely going to win and
then he waited for his opponent
pushes pawn to its doom now the Knights
going to take the pawn and if you play
h6 then you can't play this what's funny
is if the White King was on f3 then
white could actually do that but with
the White King on f2 you can imagine if
the White King was on f3 here that white
would play King e4 there would be a draw
I guess you made with a knight I forgot
is this the beginner class okay yeah
what's on passant alright so after
Knight g7 white resigned her a Eliana of
unfortunately every Eliana of game is
like the 70 moves as opponent falls
asleep like if you were at the Mike
comer lecture earlier you saw me
sleeping in the back but I needed that
sleep so okay now this is a better
engine in the last silly one this is
eliana versus some guy rated 2300 not
quite to the 2700 level of value on ax
now a lot of players would tell you the
black has the advantage because black
has a passed pawn and white doesn't but
that passed pawn is useless it can't
move it's never going to move and
White's rook is better
White's Knight is better White's King is
better and why it's going to push this
pushes King side majority and black
shits going to defend as weak pawns so
this is a big advantage for white it's
very nice to have your knight blockading
upon so the other night isn't doing
anything okay so eight 7s hanging so his
opponent played that move terrible okay
now why can't move anything or else he
loses everything
so now white can proceed on the Kings
side one of the things that Eliana of is
good at which is the trademark of a lot
of super grandmasters is he's very
patient so you know like if I tell a
joke most of you falling asleep arjan's
on the floor laughing but you got to
weigh it you gotta wait for the good
jokes okay let you see a movie like Ted
- okay the first 20 jokes not too
funny xxi joke now you're talking and
then okay 20 more beds you get a wait
get just laugh with all the jokes it's
not like the South Park movie where you
can okay so I used to laugh at
everything terrible okay so so white so
white very patient
efore advanced the majority kappa
blanket would be proud never play f6f-5
king f4 white just goes forward h4e 5
now white takes for the king
most weaker players would take with a
knight because they like attacking
things and if you take with a knight
then you're attacking the rook okay but
actually i wouldn't move my knight off
of c4 that's a great square and my king
is blowing up the board which is what i
want king b7 defending the knight
finally check g5 if Eliana was a
stronger player he'd repeat but okay g5
and black can't do anything White's King
is much better than blacks all of whites
pieces are better than blacks tag sakes
98 finally a good square for the knight
well might go to g7 a 4 a 4 I like
because black wants to play 9 check
Knight b6 kick out the knight on c4 and
then push the C pawn so white plays a 4
and then it plays king c8 because if he
plays Knight b6 right away now the only
thing defending the C pawn is the rook
so we could play Knight a5 or 95 I guess
I would go to e5 a5 seems pretty good
too and then I'm attacking the rook the
rooks going to move it I'll take your C
pawn so so we went back for no reason
okay good
my color will be proud of all these
errors and now after King c8 black has
the c7 square for his rook so now in the
same variation I just showed you
you night be 695 we could retreat the
rook but now white prevents Knight b6
again the trademark of a top player how
does white stop Knight b6 yeah
a5 although he might have played King d5
because I forgot either ways funny
I wasn't funny ok 5 and black can do
anything don't you feel sorry for black
the night the night can't go anywhere
and this rook has to stay defending this
pawn and white didn't just push his
majority that was the beginning then he
stopped blacks counter play by playing
a4 a5 black can't play Knight b6 okay so
he was his King back and forth that's
exciting
King d5 the espresso machine has spoken
now Knight b6 check isn't so good as
their supply on 85 on the other hand uh
it's sort of hard to move here for black
sir and I say that lightly yeah ex clam
a6 is legal I would move my rook
where I I don't I don't see how it
matters I wouldn't give it away
so rugby 3 yeah anywhere now you're
given and now you're giving away the b6
square so I can go there later nothing
wrong with a 6 I guess
white could try to you know take this
pawn since I don't see what black does
about it I'm sure there's something he
does advise don't know what ok so that's
what white did yeah so I did what I said
check and now black gave up because
Knight d6 is going to be annoying for
example now we're threatening me
so yeah good luck with that and also
while rookie six wins 96 threatens maid
so if you don't make a move then I do
this and if you take my hanging pawn
then I well that's I guess g6 was bad
then I g7 track is a fork so it's funny
another good thing that a lot of top
players do is when they have a plan
which I already showed Rick h1 wreck h7
take the pawn they're like well wait a
minute Ricky one check just wins because
I'm playing 96 and giving checkmate this
is a good example of active pieces
something that kind of and I have talked
about a lot not to each other oh maybe
once to each other
active pieces are very important not
just pawn structure and in this game the
last 10 moves of the game White had a
better King a better night in a better
rook and I think the key to this ending
was white actually playing a4 a5
stopping Knight to b6 and black couldn't
do anything
now this game is different than the
other games because this game is equal
and then in our Kiev who has about the
same rating as a Leonov made some
mistakes and lost now this is a very
interesting position because we have
sort of a interesting difference of idea
here White's pushing all of his pawns on
the Kings side and then black is like
okay I'll take them thank you so either
why it's going to gain a lot of space
and black can't move or blacks going to
take all of White's pawns so black is
obviously threatening the a to pawn so
he defended it and the Queen went to f1
and black is saying I don't have any
weaknesses I'm going to go attack all
your pawns and white says thank you for
the pawn and after Queen e2 we're
threatening everything a lot of times in
positions like this both sides take all
the pawn
and it's still a draw but in this
instance White's King is not as safe as
blacks King blacks King is is never
going to get checked and so if we see a
situation which we will where both sides
are queening blacks King is very safe
and since White's moved all of his pawns
his King is not very safe well first had
to defend the bishop so King c2 and
everybody takes everybody's pawns and
Queens yeah and actually uh Queen Queen
B sevens the losing move white should
have anticipated Queen g6 check with the
Queen coming in and he could have played
Queen d7 and then he could have blocked
I think the computer says this is
probably a draw but one mistaken you can
lose the game
Queen b7 is a pretty obvious move
because it stops black from queening and
it helps us to Queen unfortunately
there's other stuff going on in the
position and Queen Shaq age five age
four and and white decided don't do that
white decided my computer would break
okay and then well you can see black is
queening first because this pawn is on
the fifth rank and White's pawns on the
fourth rank and of both sides Queen them
then Black has checkmate so for example
if we just queen like in some movies
we've seen yeah then then checkmates
good yeah so White's King is very
exposed blacks King is very safe okay so
white realized both sides Queen he's not
going to work so he played Queen f3 to
stop the pawn from queening and now c-4
is a very nice move it makes the bishop
very strong it helps this Queen stop the
a pawn and it sort of puts White's King
in a mating net
and so now with the black Bishop going
either a three or c5 the APA pawns this
is very strong for white so white plate
b4 which is probably what I would do
because I don't want black to play
Bishop c5 and stop my pawn and I have
two pawns that can Queen now
unfortunately the point on c4 is really
strong so I think white just didn't see
them move c4 if you take the pawn on c4
then you got nothing that the black
Bishop goes to c5 and I mean White has
no chance of the Queen anything now the
problem with b4 is now black can attack
the white king from the other side of
the board
so what moves you black make here Queen
g6 is you know we've seen that before
it's not a big move what's that Queen a
one that's my recollection but I've
looked at this game in like 20 years was
played last year - yeah Queen a one
now we're threatening Queen takes a four
check so probably should stop that you
played f5 yeah hey fives what I would do
um let's see if I play a five I'm for
seeing some kind of Queen a three Bishop
b4 scenario seems like that has to work
yeah this this works yeah yeah now I'm
going to play Queen a3 and Bishop before
that's too bad so for example while this
is legal right yeah and then I take this
guy now Bishop a3 mate is annoying and
if you check always play Bishop fa8 yeah
yeah so there's nothing you can do about
that because if you play King to c1 I
can just do the same thing and then
Bishop takes b4 is the next move and
this is pinned here so yeah c4 was a
great move and that actually turned the
tables he played at five again f5 is
sort of the mirror image of c4 White's
activating his bishop
but ok he's already losing a pawn so
yeah he's and he's got nothing now just
down upon check no Queen g7 made its
check always played Bishop f8 and yeah
somehow he's not resigning resigned here
that's a good idea
yeah Queen's coming so that was a funny
game because white at a pass to a pawn
and black had a past H pawn but White's
King was also exposed and normally in
the endgame you don't think about check
reading your opponent but actually you
should always think about it because
that's how you win and so at this game
with white pushing all of his pawns on
both sides I think actually white moved
all of his pawns yeah white moved every
pawn he had and blacks King was very
safe so White's King was getting checked
and there were lots of forks and pins
and blacks King just sent on g8 okay so
he won that game and that was actually a
very important game in a strong
tournament because that guy's not so bad
you don't give me any of that you can't
tell me what to do all right of course
Aliannah was white because he had black
the last game and so we have to flip the
board okay yeah and again this is
actually like the other Eliana of game
that he won the first game we looked at
we are he also had four against three on
the Kings side and black had an extra
pass pawn on the Queen side the problem
is what that means is that pawn if it's
on the second third or fourth rank it's
not going to Queen that's on the seventh
rank in my queen and the side that has
more pawns has the safe for King and
obviously White's going to try double on
the seventh rank and white is stopping
black from doing the same okay but first
things first the Bishop on e5 is
attacked so he do he moved it away
g4 we're going to attack h4 and there's
just like no way to stop g5 it's
unfortunate
and he's going to play g5 yeah and so
black is defending his F pawn in case of
the doubling the rooks Black's defending
this pawn black is stopping g5 black is
just much worse and here the fact that
White's moving his pawns is actually
giving him more space so his King is
actually safer okay Bishop da not a good
Bishop I would I mean this guy's the
same rating as me but who's that guy so
I don't play moves like Bishop d8 unless
my bishop goes to a better square if I
was black I would like sacrifice my be
pawn trade rooks and try to draw a pawn
down because I this would be pretty good
except I'm down upon and here I'm not
down upon but I mean that's that's just
terrible so I don't I don't deactivate
my pieces trying to save a pawn if my
pieces can't move that's that's much
worse than upon okay Knight d4 and white
had a really good idea here then I think
black never saw I think black was really
worried about Knight f5 or as we say in
my class knife f5 and I think black was
very concerned about that and rightfully
so and as you can see a lot of my
students they say things like I have a
passed pawn while past pawns are good
when you can Queen them but we're on the
second and third rank and they can't
move that's just a weak fun and well
Bishop idea just can't move it's
terrible okay rugby to attacking upon he
defended it
rugby one with no idea Age 5
basically I went backwards and you did
that Wow
I blame Mike comer so basically so I
can't go backwards so white wants to
play Knight f5 at some point and just
making sure that g6 is never playable
cementing the position very patient okay
and then he puts his works on the 7th
yeah and now a very surprising idea it
looks like black just sits here and
moves his rook around forever but White
has a brilliant winning idea an idea is
based on the fact that this pawn can
move if you were ever going to listen to
me again if you ever are this is finally
my rule comes to fruition never play I
have sex if you thought f6 was met in
your games it's really bad here f6
getting checkmated well it's not that
you can't just play f6 you can't move
the F Quan at all because then Rick
takes g7 leads to me so I don't know why
take advantage of this yeah that enter
is better than mine maybe after 96 I
play rook d2 but I'm too old to analyze
that now you can play rook f7 Rick f7
Knight f7 that's also good for black
yeah 96 is good yeah he played out for
because he's patient he didn't do any of
the winning moves he's just moving
around doing nothing
yeah okay and then he played Knight g4
as you suggested yeah
and then if the knight moves black plays
rook takes rook so what did whites you
to stop rook takes rook
kingi two very good now
black played nothing the computer says
rook takes Knight is the best move black
sound two better move by resigning
if you don't sacrifice your rook with a
completely lost position and just save
your rook now we finally play the
winning move 96 and we're threatening
these two pieces and if you take you get
mated of course nobody in my class would
play checkmate they would repeat and and
then checkmate obviously I was playing a
guy once and I had like queen Shaq on h3
and he moved his king and queen takes
bishop on b3 and i'll be up like four
pieces and instead of doing that i
repeated like queen age three to g4 and
h3 and then he resigned while i was
repeating and then he said why didn't
you take my bishop but i'm like you
resign it could have made you resigned
earlier yeah 96 yeah so this is funny
you know I mean probably this is a young
player the guy was black I don't know
who it is young players don't want to
lose all their pieces they do any limit
this is a one who higher rated players
older players they don't mind losing a
pawn if everything's active if the
alternative is to put your pieces here
and not move them because the b-pawn is
useless that's not that that pawn didn't
move but having your pieces tied on the
back rank where they can't move you just
can't do that you just lose so that game
looked like a very easy win for why when
probably why was just a little better
and it would have been a lot more sense
for black to not play Bishop to da in
this position and just lose the pawn you
know move the rook I don't know and then
if he takes the pawn he's not going to
checkmate us so he's you have to win
this pawn up endgame which may or may
not be a win I don't know if I was black
I'd hoped to draw if I was white I play
a thousand moves but the way the game
went black had no hope his Bishop was on
da and white just did whatever he want
and the pawn that black save didn't
really help him like that pawns useless
White's pieces are all good the bishop
on d8 is terrible
again I would be playing this ship f6
here giving my pawn away although when
the black rook was defending it
if white took the pawn we could trade
rooks and black wants to trade rooks
because White's richer double the
seventh rank and blacks workers on f8
defending terrible okay so that was a
nice nice one freely on of nice and
boring like he likes it
good good system we got here good job
okay now this came I like the most
because it was a draw and black didn't
draw also
Eliana of his wife sought to switch the
board anymore yay all right
so a lot of players in this room would
just agree to a draw here because both
sides have to connected passed pawns so
you wouldn't think there's a lot to do
here okay but in fact not only did black
lose black lost immediately that's the
way to do it okay so what white wants to
do is take the pawn on d5 with its check
because it's a knight now
see check not and it blocks the C pawn
oh wait that's a king okay so the king
wants to take the pawn both sides Queen
and whites upon ahead and black can
easily stop that by playing what move
ke5 allows eise evan very risky it does
stop my plan though so you're still
right but it allows another plan which
is favorable to white right king e5 e 7
then white probably wins anyone else
yeah King e7 to g6 and then you agree to
a draw yeah okay but instead black here
you should play King e7 yeah instead
black point h5 and says like well to
draw okay King e7 is a draw because if
you take then then black wins and if you
don't take then I go King here King here
draw and the game would have been a draw
I guarantee it black will play King D 67
they're going to be do a draw so you
have to look out for this never give up
trying to win and never think
everything's a dead draw King e7 is a
dead draw nobody can win but after h5
White's not winning but White's much
better now it's good to be white which
move did white play proving his
advantage King takes d5 and both sides
Queen everybody's happy except now
White's a pawn ahead and if black starts
checking white a thousand moves in a row
which is the usual way to draw then my
King guides over here and takes your
pawns while it's hiding so White's a
pawn up White's threatening what's this
a queen of fates mate yeah queen g6 is
mate right and that might be it and quit
yeah thanks yeah good job and Queen
sakes age five wins upon over the
objections of the computer and again if
black goes check check check White's
King goes and takes the Queen side pawns
so black went from a dead draw to a much
worse ending and I'm only guessing that
black just didn't see King takes d5
because if you see King takes d5 you
just play King e7 here and there's
nothing you can't play King takes d5 now
because of c3 so terrible move in Eliana
have won the better ed game two pawns to
one and that's not necessarily that
White's winning but why it's very close
to winning if not winning White's pawn
is further advanced and white has more
pawns and here black resigned because if
you check then I interpose the Queen and
if you don't check I Queen if you stop
me from queening I'll check you and then
Queen yes you could always ask questions
kingi five might might win it might lose
the only way to figure out the analyze
it I'm going to play C three you're
going to check and I'm going to move my
king I'm not going to tell you where
that would give it away yeah let's go
here I don't know
so now if you play e7 if I'm not saying
you place I said F now if you were at a
previous lecture of mine where I showed
the game then fine gold miles artemon
was I white yeah what's the winning move
here for black if you saw that game
you'll figure it out
close king d7 yeah I did something
similar against argument he didn't see
so he resigned now you know you got
nothing King d7 I mean I think what 19
does that so e 7 is not so good f 7
looks also not so good right so King D 6
okay and then I'm going to play C I'm
going to play that I agree and then okay
you're going to get one of these
scenarios but I don't I don't think
black is unhappy blacks the one who's a
pawn up now so this probably a draw but
White's probably not better why not why
it's not better because the computer
says all zeroes after King g7 so
there are but as we saw not there but
yeah and maybe blacks saw that but
didn't see King takes d5 King takes d5
is the same except the deep ones gone we
get the same Queen upon endgame except
white as an extra pawn instead of being
down upon so age five was really
terrible yeah and there are situations
where you do that and sometimes you win
stems you lose an example at the chess
club here I'm sure you all remember
snicker snicker was the game Karpov
Serra one match game one from their
blitz match they played like to slow
games and to rapid games those are all
draws you guys remember that right right
that's correct and then they played
blitz they played like ten blitz games
something like that the first blitz game
Sarah won had a winning king upon
anything any lost it was just like this
there was like both sides Queen and
there was a maid and they both had like
five seconds left so he made whatever
the worst legal move was ever and
probably that came to the database even
though it's a blitz game because we
recorded them undg cheese so you'll
actually see a example of this where one
side was winning and they lost yeah yes
sir was winning and he lost the rest of
the match didn't go well he did a
Carlsen before Carlsen did it and least
but not last was actually a good player
although in our kids a good player vote
I check and this is very surprising
because this looks like the most drawn
of all drawn positions in fact some
people would think White's better and
it's too bad of eve's not here because
if he will be here on Sunday for a
couple weeks
V Friedman your favorite lecturer yeah
he's actually an FST and barnes-jewish
said he was fine so you have to worry
about that man what a slow audience and
I saw you got it right away
yeah immediately
yeah people at home are still confused
there are people at home we'll get up
tomorrow they'll be like all been okay
now the reason I mentioned de vivre
wasn't because of you know his obvious
you know deformities it was because Aviv
had an ending very similar except there
were no be pawns and the other guys rook
was on b5 so like white was just killing
it like black was struggling to draw and
ended up winning the endgame like he was
impossible but he won like there was a
white rook here and this rule couldn't
move on a7 but you want anyway okay now
here black is actually better because
there's something more important than
the rookie activity in this particular
position it's actually two things that
are more important one is obvious King
activity and one you don't know because
you know that's why you're low rated I
am no one is the advanced placement of
the pawns in fact Alex your Malinsky
who's you know he's been wrong before
he's probably not wrong here he said
that's the most important of all King
and pawn and rook and pawn endings your
Malinsky likes when the pawns are close
to queening I'm not sure why oh yeah he
likes the Queen okay and obviously this
pawn is the closest to queening that's
on the fifth rank and you're not taking
that pond so while white is busy taking
this pawn and I am busy taking that pawn
my pawns on the fifth rank your pawns on
the fourth rank and my King is active
and your Kings on g2 so this is a big
advantage for black even though the
computer wants to shut down it's still a
big advantage for black doesn't matter
see it goes away it's like alright okay
and black plays King for gets his King
up there
now there's nothing white can do
obviously blacks King can run over and
take the be pawn because white is
stopping that but there's no way to stop
my rook from taking the pawn and okay
why it's going to win this fun I'm going
to win this pawn but my pawns further
advanced and more importantly my king is
on e4 and your King is a spectator
so actually white/black won fairly
easily rook c4 check move is
f-for kind of counterplay is that okay
now the black rook swings over and takes
the pawn on b2 or b3 King age three so
obviously if I take I'm going to go take
with the king and then my king is
attacking your opponent and queening so
white is like you're not going to take
with your king I'm going to leave my
rook here so he activated his King he's
going to try to you know act you know
get some counter play over here King g4
with a fork rub takes a5 rook to e7
now that move shocked me because I was
expecting rook takes b3 when I looked at
the game earlier but after Ricky seven
there's no counter play against these
pawns and there's no defense to king c3
King takes b3 that's a real professional
move Ricky seven if Rick takes b3 which
is also good for black now White has
really good drawing chances because this
pawn is going to fall my king is moving
up I have a passed pawn but after Ricky
seven there's no way you're going to win
these pawns my king is going to do this
and the white King's not doing anything
blacks King is helping the b-pawn Queen
it's attacking the a4 pawn and as
Gregory Caetano said to me once black is
up a king actually I was black against
him and the game he's talking about so
he did say that I was playing kite
enough once at the US Championship in
Tulsa hold on a second thinking a Tulsa
don't go to Tulsa anyway
I'm playing this change of in Tulsa and
I had down two pawns they look upon
ending that was the best I could hope
for in any game but my King was active
and his King was on h1 and I drew and he
said yeah you can't win without a king I
was down a king
okay so black gets his King active stops
the a pawn yeah and then why it's got
nothing here comes the pawn
and if we play something like King g4 or
king h4 then I can play rook check and
Rick before so that would be inadvisable
so g4 not blacks threatening rook to be
for getting a queen so White has two
choices he could take the pawn what else
can he do
resign so he chose the resigning one it
well worked before you're a queen ahead
sorry we can't let that happen
the problem is you can't play g5 and
start running with your F pawn that that
doesn't work out too well okay and if
you don't play g5 you're going to have
to lose 800 Tempe with your King and
that you got nothing yeah you gotta yeah
and then if you want to be super precise
I'm not saying you do want to be icing
if you want to be super precise then you
go here that's really mean yeah if you
don't want to be super-sized you go here
if you want to be sort of like boring
about ego here or you could let it be
white smooth and white can resign also
good because you pin the pun and rook
check wins and every legal avoids okay
so that was very nice bye Aliannah
because when the game started it wasn't
even clear who was better here this
looks like four against four whites rook
is better than blacks but with blacks
King being better and with the trait of
these pawns favoring black black's pawn
is closer to queening blacks King is
much closer to white spawns blacks King
is helpful in whites isn't and my
favorite move of the game rookie 7 in
this position just rookie 7 stopping
white from taking the Jeep on but white
black still wins the b3 pawn temporarily
blacks upon down but he wins easily and
that's against a pretty good player vote
at chick as you all know actually one of
you knows I can't yeah I look at him
nodding does he know the question yet
and he still knows the answer what no no
he knows the answer vote our chick was
who's second and the wool championship
match
yeah of is she yeah so he's not as bad
as he plays
I think everybody was Karlsson second
yeah anyway Ananda's on fire as you know
he's number two in the world now by
rating point six ahead or point one and
something and Eleana of unfortunately
even though he's always over 2700 he's
sort of overshadowed by ponomaryov and
even chuck because they live in the same
country and they're better than him so
he's the third banana
he's the Wesley so of the Ukraine except
except Wesley so his number top ten in
the world so he gets a little more props
that he's number eight in the world
usually when you're number eight in the
world you're not number three in your
country unless it was 1950 60s
Soviet Union then you were number nine
in your country and you were number
eight in the world you know what I'm
saying yeah that's a tough country you
could be the world champion kick off the
Olympiad team yeah